that's not the plan
but you like that's who she's always
been she's always been you still get to
see the kids yeah she does I do I handle
that more so than him he doesn't I don't
get listen
I don't want to be in charge of no kids
I don't want to be responsible
this is great no I will look listen wait
let me land the kids are fine let me
laugh I mean listen oh that's why I
don't need to finish that okay that's
why she hasn't worked because I know you
know when I have kids with people I I
don't like
people
well I want to go exactly we've only had
one experience but yeah but when I had
kids with her I was always happy I was
always sure I was always like
I'm not a babysitter bro I'm a provider
a leader protector that's what a man is
to me somebody who's going to provide
lead and protect that's all I know how
to do so you're not interested in like a
day with the kids at Disneyland just you
know definitely he could never do he
could definitely do that though that's
about it though maybe if they're maybe
if they're like like walking they can go
in the bathroom
no diapers no bottles none of that like
we all eat the same thing and stuff
maybe absolutely then he I I think he
could yeah I'll get you a corn dog but
diaper bag formula he is so nice I gotta
get out there and get it bro yeah okay
I'm a baby how am I making any money for
the baby so you're not doing the
airplane and you know how much it cost
to raise a baby it is you got a reason
for 18 years I'll trust me it costs
about seven wait listen yeah I have my
kids it costs about it costs about ten
thousand dollars a month buddy you're
who are you I have grown children
there's 12 months in a year that's 120
000.
ten thousand dollars a month it costs
ten thousand dollars I mean
I know it costs for your baby to have a
room a bed
a school a ride to school food to eat at
school it cost ten thousand dollars a
month
that kid's living well
hey I every every kid should live well I
liked it I liked it should live well
depending on what happens with this kid
that you're expecting we might want to
walk back that figure a little to maybe
like three thousand dollars a month in
case they come at you for child support
no I'm not worried about that
because
I've made her good enough to use her
she's good she can use her name anywhere
and get anything she she wants she
doesn't need you know
so I'm not making her dependent of me I
didn't for you you're not interested in
babysitting I can't bro I'm a provide
lead and protect and babysit
I mean it's it's possible
yeah for one two days maybe even three
days
do you think
because I think that like
there's certain moments in your kid's
life that are more influential than
others 100 and also there's just stuff
that like you know you're only gonna be
around for once 100
so make sure you're there yeah so you're
so you're gonna be around for once right
yeah I just mean there's like certain
moments in every kid's life you're gonna
be around for once right so just be
there are you gonna take the kids what's
the hard part about that let's say your
son starts playing basketball you're
taking my son plays football practice
football playback he's been there he's
been there I mean your teacher my son
goes to school I'll take him you know I
can't take him every day but at least
three to four days out of the week I'm
gonna attempt too that's amazing
I'm not a Debbie but I'm not like I
think it's clear you're not a deadbeat
yeah no definitely not absolutely no of
course not because if you were a
deadbeat I have to leave provide and
protect well you can't leave for Valley
protect and
be there every when you wake up when you
go to sleep when you eat lunch when he
do you feel me something you got to go
to work even if you work a nine to five
and you have a kid
eight hours of the day you're not with
the kid you're working Jaden what would
be for you his biggest strength as a
father and something you'd like to see
him improve on yeah
hmm okay great question
um
strength is that
I think that everyone thinks that he's
not around but he is around we don't we
live in the same general area he's
around multiple times a week obviously
now there's one mile for me he's
obviously on house arrest now but you
know what I'm saying we've already made
the effort to do that I don't he's not
an absent dad so that's not his weakness
what he could improve on would maybe be
like
disciplining I don't think that I think
that I'm more the like I have to you got
to lay the hammer yeah because he won
every day yeah and he wants to come
around yeah like he's like I got
presents and I have we can get we can we
can get wings 70 Wings let's get 70
wings like you want to jump off the roof
let's jump off through it like he's that
but I think that as far as disciplining
he could help me a little more because I
think that our son is getting to the age
where it's kind of like I don't have to
listen to Mom he's six oh yeah he's
getting there he's like he's kind of
like I don't have to listen to him he's
been a kid though it's not like he's
yeah but like I can't even give him a
cuss like it's not like he's doing
belligerent things yeah it's more like
he's he won't listen he's finding out
his controls you feel me it's like when
you when you with your mom all day
because obviously I'm dealing with this
find out what she gonna say you're not
going to care if you're jumping off your
bed uh she's gonna be one in August so
it's kind of like I'm dealing with her I
don't he's like I'm gonna jump off the
bed okay great jump off the bed I'm
dealing I'm changing a dirty diaper like
great and then he'll jump off the bed
but also do three backflips and then
it's like I didn't tell you to do that
you know what I mean like I didn't tell
you to do that so why are you doing
nothing out of the ordinary he's being
sick but I need him to be like I need
you to I need you to listen to Mom
unplug the PlayStation yes yes because
sometimes he'll I'll be like clean your
room take a shower then you can play
Playstation yeah take that [__]
no he'll empty the whole Toy Box like
I'm not cleaning [__] I'm not taking a
shower none of that I'm gonna just play
Playstation why would you do that it's
hard for me to like be mean to him
that's what I mean like sometimes she be
doing overboard though it's like she'd
be just tripping off
overboard it's having it's having like
he like can I get a snack no you can't
get no [__] snacks what the [__] down
no because he's like damn the snacks you
can let him have three snacks before
dinner why are you having three sexy
you're not gonna eat dinner exactly and
then you're gonna stay up all night
again um next in black and Asian so this
is the thing about a Mexican woman if
you don't eat dinner because my wife's
Mexican they serious
I might [__] some food no at work and if
I come home and my wife's got and she
she'll know vegetables she'll be like oh
you ate something before you came home
didn't you because you ain't [__] up
that food like you should be and it's
like damn it's not that serious it is
though because then when they're when
you're knocked out Drool on the pillow
at 12 a.m and they're like a little
sandwich
that's fine